I've already had 805
C4
take Luer F5 4 G6 E6 pretty much every
breeding that doesn't adjust anything has
already been done here now he has
taken it away so and now black has
a
choice again yes that's an interesting
move I have the impression that he does
n't know his way around
a bit
but
yes, well, well, it's interesting
Knight G5 is actually the
main move but Knight A3 is also
interesting
so that's how
you turn the opening here into a
real
gambit
the type of opening ne
with G3 and so on but white often actually has
compensation here wow he tries here directly
what
tactical knight E5 takes queen
D4 and then
skewers here whereby this is a bit
common
here look here does it really work or is
there another trick here  with
White I don't see any, well, well, we have to
develop so white
definitely has a bit of a
developmental advantage for the pawn
and maybe some pressure on the gut. Wing
is trying to work with tricks here again. Knight
E5 knight runner
again D with D5 at the end  It's starting to get
a bit
annoying, so the question now is
whether you have to play here straight away
somehow or whether you play calmly here,
so you definitely have
a bit of something here in the long term.
Knight C4 E4 D3 would be
possible and Knight C4 straight away might be
interesting, yes I have to  move
at some point even if it is interesting
to look at the position
so now there are ideas like knight F5
in the
position so if he
were to develop the bishop now e.g. then knight
F5 is possible, not fatal or anything like that but
is definitely a good field  for
the
knight so SPI there active yes okay but
I can still
go here now so knight
D6 would now be
possible or maybe play actively
so D3 or something
h very difficult I'll do it with
the IDE F3 I don't know open the F line
What's difficult here, it
knows has somehow a bit of
compensation but
um it's not that easy to
play so you have to
sometimes you would like a little more time, um
so that's now according to the
plan more worries than the position causes
To me here the time that has really
run down really well again
seems pretty unclear, I
mean maybe we don't do it all that
well here, I can take it here too,
but I was really slow again for everyone,
yes, it's such a simple chess, where am
I going?  yes,
of course I must not have exactly planned to give up
the beautiful bishop here after the games h
yes, that should now be good for
Black no, it's hard to see that you should
still have compensation here.
I would have been more worried about knight D5
now we still have it
super runner on G2,
you also have a bit of pressure on the
queenside C5, I'll make queen
E5, so it's not bad for
Black, but what's the idea and if
he lets me, I'll just do it with C5,
yes, that should now
be compensation again, like the knight
take away the only really good
figure
so now I was hoping I could do
something here on the on the that's not a
real
pin at all so well but maybe
jumper 6 or rook A7
take something away
Check back row was still
weak
Check
I actually thought knight D7
would be  what threatens it threatens but nothing at all
shame check
stupid
D
handed back to me
check check check check
god he suddenly got really fast oh crap crap yeah
good yeah good fight game
somehow somehow I was doing
quite well again and then I did a
bad job, yes
little  Of course I had time